dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur pierre charon
pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président un ministre sous
le président de la commission des lois
l'un des rapporteurs mes chers collègues
si notre travail de législateur consiste
souvent à trouver les ajustements
nécessaires au bon fonctionnement de la
société
il est également éminemment symbolique
la loi une valeur qui dépasse le droit
une valeur de construction sociale elle
est un socle sur lequel nous bâtissons
humblement la civilisation
dès lors mes chers collègues devant la
quantité de défis et de difficultés que
rencontre la france aujourd'hui je vous
avoue mon incompréhension de voir votre
énergie d'élus se porter sur l'amnistié
d'infractions commises dans le cadre du
syndicalisme ou pour utiliser votre
langage de la lutte sociale
sur le plan symbolique tout d'abord
comment alors que l'égalité est
aujourd'hui réclamée sur tous les sujets
établir un traitement d'exception pour
les militants politiques concernant le
non respect de la loi
comment expliquer aux français qu'ils
doivent respecter la loi si dans le même
temps on exonère une partie de la
population de sa responsabilité
élémentaire de citoyens au seul prétexte
son activité militante autant exposé des
motifs laisse entendre que la défense de
l'intérêt général passe presque
inévitablement par l'infraction ou le
délit
quelle vision étrange du militantisme ou
salées de ma vie politique et
associative
j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer de
nombreux militants qui défendent et
leurs idéaux de la façon la plus honnête
sans casse et sans calomnier et sans
séquestrer
faut-il incité ses militants à ne pas
respecter la loi de tous j'ai le plus
grand respect pour la défense de
conviction mais voulons-nous d'un pays
où le militantisme syndical sème la
pagaille ou la terreur je me permet
d'utiliser ses mots car je suis toujours
très choqués devant les violences qui
ont tous régulièrement les
revendications sociales dites au piquet
de la jeune héritière s'il va rentrer
alors est ce que c'est normal
un musée vous entre vous
je voudrais évoquer des faits très
récent qui éclaire précisément ce texte
est notre discussion
la situation de la fonderie des emmy de
vaud dans l'allier où un groupe
d'ouvriers a littéralement truffe l
usine d'explosifs et deux bouteilles de
gaz menaçant de tout faire sauter dans
le cadre des négociations de reprise à
l'heure à laquelle nous parlons les
détonateurs sont toujours en place la
défense de l'emploi est évidemment un
combat important mais nous pouvons
imaginer qu'il soit le prétexte à ce
genre d'intimidation
je souhaite également mentionné la grève
qui paralyse lusine et sa d'aulnay nous
apprenions la semaine dernière que 200
grévistes de l'usiné d'aulnay qu on
t'avait il cite d'un sous traitant du
val d'oise afin de maintenir la pression
je vous rappelle que cette usine est
paralysée depuis cinq semaines par 500
grévistes alors que les usines s'emploie
à 2800 personnes
qu'avez vous à dire à ces familles qui
ne toucheront pas leur salaire
là mes chers collègues
qu'avez vous à dire à ces ouvriers qui
se voit intimider quotidiennement dans
leur travail
qu'avez vous à dire au père de famille
qui sont faits un jour séquestrés parce
qu'ils ont eu la mauvaise idée de
devenir patron du sinn
nous avons mes chers collègues une
responsabilité vis à vis des français et
notre rôle mais pas celui d'excusés ce
qui ne doit pas l'être pour des raisons
idéologiques et clientéliste la date
vous avez choisi pour délimiter le
contour de cette amnistie est à cet
égard très éloquente dont la mesure où
il s'agit des actes commis avant le 6
mai 2012
en somme qui ne viennent pas à l'idée
des militants de profiter de cette
proposition de loi pour aller semer le
désordre sous françois hollande
elle ne concerne que les militants
résistants qui chahutaient la présidence
de nicolas sarkozy
peut-être respirer vous avec cette date
tenir les syndicats par la promesse de
l'amnesty pendant le mandat de françois
hollande
mes chers collègues quelles que soient
vos motivations nous ne pouvons pas
envoyer ce signal aux français nous ne
pouvons pas d'ailleurs l'envoyé non plus
au reste du monde
quel repreneur va vouloir se pencher sur
les entreprises d'un pays
qui amnistie les délits quand ils sont
le fait du militantisme syndical
voulons nous vraiment détourné tous les
investisseurs et entrepreneurs de notre
économie
j'espère pour ma part dans cette période
difficile que le monde syndical sera
être un acteur responsable qui préférera
toujours le respect et le dialogue à
l'entêtement et au désordre au moment où
les chiffres du chômage qui veulent
obtenir a évoqué tout à l'heure explose
avec quarante mille nouveaux chômeurs ce
mois ci nous approchons du triste record
de 1997
notre devoir est de préserver la paix
sociale cette proposition de loi va
malheureusement dans le sens contraire
de cet impératif et reviendra à verser
de l'huile sur le feu syndicale c'est
pourquoi mes chers collègues le groupe
ump votera contre ce texte
je vous remercie